Morris is fronted by Williams job for  quartet  that's what you're missing John roll  with a perfect pass to the Machine John  Wall and that quick crossover goes  baseline and scores he's got seven  points from all ten of their attempts  here's wall lurking fires a pass for  Pele beautifully done  get pulled the assistant his seventh of  the game and keep it alive wall into the  quarter  Pele again how do you like that timeout  Charlotte point play the fact that  analytics has said that's what you want  to do they look for that line rather  than take what is an open shot one of  the worst shots in basketball it's being  on the three-point line  whether she Hills or your toes wall  stays in the game screen for Gortat back  to marching for the slam  that was a hammer Walker drive blocked  by Porter wall for Porter's jumper for  three is good mix aha okuu whoa with a  great crossover drives score the field  goal he'll go to the line  [Applause]